what's the worst thing that's happened
to you physically
from fighting uh broken heart
really i would say but i mean when uh
man you know losing to gsp was up one
thing but when i
when i drew with bj penn i kind of knew
what that meant
and uh it was like because of the way
that
they worked where their system works
like i had you know i lost the gsp and i
won five more fights and i was supposed
to get a title shot but i wasn't playing
ball and i wasn't being a good boy
i would say give me the title shot i
took it away they made me fight bj
and um yeah with me getting that draw it
was a chance for them to start
pushing me aside and and never give me
another title shot again so that after
that fight
i think yeah i kind of my heart was kind
of broken
except what do you mean by not not being
like a good little boy
um well because they're not uh they're
not a
just get this those people off but mma
here the fights are real
but it's not a sport it does not
function to operate as a sport
there are there are mechanics around a
sport that happen
um where there's no restrictions around
you know
uh elevation sport you know you win you
get a ranking you you move up that's
just the way it is like nobody's outside
presence can can take that away uh in
in what ufc does it's a production it's
like wwe
they are the ones who give the rankings
they're the one who gives the belt
they decide everything it doesn't matter
what your merit
is within the sport of winning or losing
they just get to cast
who goes where so it's like a um
i mean it's about the money it's about
getting eyeballs on the show and
whatever they think is
there's no leverage for the fighter
because there's nowhere else to go
you're stuck in this never-ending
contract
usually and you can't to another
promoter and the promoters don't even
compete with each other
uh in boxing you would have the option
of
potentially you know going to a
different promoter and then
you'd still have option to fight for it
um a sanctioned belt you know because
they have they have um
sanctioning bodies that control else in
boxing it's like the promoter doesn't
control the belt
it's kind of like the nfl the nfl is in
charge of
um rankings and match-ups and
and the title the trophy but like no one
team is like the dallas cowboys they
don't get
they don't control the belt they don't
control the nfl title
they don't control whether or not oh you
know what we're gonna make more money
with this team
in the finals so we're going to let our
cowboys play
um you said that you had a broken heart
you know as a result of all that like is
it a broken heart in the same sort of
way like a girl broke your heart or is
it
in a way kind of a worse because it was
uh
um it was like you know you're playing
to win you know you're like i have a
tiger like you put everything in your
life
into this this outcome you know that was
the the ufc title
and you feel them like nope you're just
never going to get that shot again
we don't we just don't like you you
start to
you know that's a heartbreak like
there's no way to get to where you want
to be
i got the impression watching some of
the videos that i came across
on youtube that you kind of had an
acrimonious
relationship with dana white and the ufc
can you talk about that i always knew
that it was
not right like think about like when gsp
got his
title shot with matthews he he got on
his knees and he begged
he begged the promoter to let him please
have a title shot
what what sport have you ever heard of
where the best player
begs to play for the title
does tom brady get on his knees and ask
the nfl commissioner can you please
allow me
to participate in this game for the for
the best team
no he earns it he earned it through
winning and accomplishments
but that's not that's not how it works
and you can see that
over and over and over again uh even
even with the
you know the uh the talks right now with
jon jones wanting more money
for his fight uh to fight nagao at
heavyweight
he has every right to ask for more but
he's making the mistake of asking for a
dollar sign instead of
percentage he needs to be asking for a
cut of what the
the revenue is not oh i want eight
million dollars he should be asking for
a
percent give me 55 percent of the
revenue how much does a
does a top-ranked fighter make these
days
well like the guy that has a title you
know
and then plus like any kind of
sponsorships or endorsements from
everyone
if you win the belt and then you defend
the belt okay so you have to
two times so if you're in the belt you
get pay-per-view points
once you get pay-per-view points then
then you start making millions per fight
just about
um but these guys are making anywhere
from 1 million to
i guess 8 million is somewhere in the uh
in the pay with all all all money
disclosed non-disclosed bonuses it's
like on an annual basis or
no that would be for one fight that's
very oh for one fight
that's very minimal for those guys that
do that [ __ ]
you know you're talking less than 10
guys ever
okay right where where the uh and
and if you look at those numbers you
think it's a lot but the um
the output that ufc is paying they're
paying like 19
of the revenues out to the fighters okay
okay and that's just event revenues
that's not even
the other half of the stuff they're
doing with with uh merchandising
and you fought up until your early 40s
so is that typical
like for a lifespan for a fighter or is
that a little bit longer than what you'd
want to go normally
way longer i for ufc
um it's actually like less than a year
for
uh average career and
how were you when you started it i
started fighting at 25-24
that's pretty long that i mean that was
that was over 15 years right
i thought 18 years yeah and i've seen
joe rogan talk about how he didn't get
into professional fighting because
of you know watching a lot of guys with
like damage to their body and their
brain and
you know like permanent kind of [ __ ]
like is it is it really that
that bad happens a lot it's one of the
reasons why i've
uh taken up a lot in fighting you know
trying to organize fighters and mixed
martial arts fire association like we
have gone i've gone paid out of pocket
to um
to the capital and uh and and
gotten people to sign up for our bill to
get the aliyah expect
expanded to uh all combat support
athletes not just
not just uh boxers um you know
uh the the class action lawsuit we've
got going with ufc too
like all that stuff's kind of all
motivated because i've seen guys
you know give their heart and soul and
then they're they're kind of brain
damaged and they can't
they can't remember [ __ ] now and they
got bad hips and they
they've got nothing and they can't even
they can't even profit
off of the fights they had a long time
ago
ufc still has people pay for their their
fight pass and can you still watch mark
coleman fights
like they still make money off of those
fights so but the fighter doesn't get
any of that
no wow
you